ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 30A
und bis 30 D
Beratung mehrerer Vorlagen zu Änderungen
des Aufenthalts und Asylrechts über den
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung zur
Einführung eines Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht rechtes werden wir
später namentlich abstimmen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne die Aussprache und das Wort
hat zuerst für die SPD-Fraktion hell
gelingt
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
das Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz
bricht mit dem
unwürdigen Zustand dass wir Jahre ja ja
zehntelang geduldet haben dass Menschen
perspektivlos im Zustand der
Kettenbildung Leben das betrifft allein
im Stichtag 31.10 dieses Jahres über
137.000 Menschen mit einem Aufenthalt
von mehr als fünf Jahren
dieses Aufenthaltsgesetz zusammen mit
der Einführung einer
behördenunabhängigen
asylverfahrensberatung mit Anpassung und
Modernisierung im Bleiberecht mit der
asylverfahrensbeschleunigung mit der
Öffnung von
Integrationskursen für Asylsuchende
insgesamt diese Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz ist ein Gesetz der
Vernunft und es ist ein Gesetz des
gesunden Menschenverstandes
und es ist ein Gesetz der Mitte und es
ist ein Gesetz der vernünftigen Mitte
davon reden wir hier die herausragende
Zahl der Menschen in unserem Land all
die guten an einem guten Zusammenleben
interessierten deutschen finden es
sinnhaft was wir hier machen wir haben
hinter uns ein breites Bündnis das
reicht von Menschen die wissen was es
bedeutet mit Menschen die Duldung Leben
zusammenzuarbeiten Unternehmerinnen
Unternehmer
Arbeitgeberverbände Industrie und
Handelskammer und es reicht bis zu
denjenigen die als Aktivisten oder in
Kirchengemeinden Synagogen geduldete
betreuen und begleiten das ist das
breite Bündnis von dem wir hier reden
und von dem wir sprechen deshalb sage
ich ausdrücklich diese Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz ist kein
sozialdemokratisches Gesetz
ist auch kein grünes Gesetz es ist auch
kein liberales Gesetz sondern es ist ein
Gesetz der Vernunft und wenn wir sagen
das ist ein soziale demokratisches
Gesetz oder ein grünes oder liberales
Gesetz dann ist es genauso ein Gesetz
des Konservatismus dem konservativ denkt
muss man auch dieses Gesetz unterstützen
in konservativ bedeutet auch Maß und
Mitte zu finden nicht egoistisch zu
denken und zu erkennen was für Menschen
wichtig ist wenn sie Perspektiven haben
wollen wenn sie sich anstrengen und
bemühen und deswegen
würde ich auch würde ich auch
ausdrücklich dass mindestens 19
Mitglieder der CDU und CSU-Fraktion in
einer persönlichen Erklärung deutlich
gemacht haben welche Punkte sie nicht
teilen dass sie im Grundsatz aber die
Idee
langfristig geduldeten Menschen die sich
gut integriert haben die Teil dieser
Gesellschaft geworden sind aber als
solche nicht wirklich leben können eine
Perspektive erhalten durch den Chancen
Aufenthalt und das kritisiere ich
überhaupt nicht nein das ist Ausdruck
von Demokratie Hochachtung prominente
dabei wie Herr Laschet wie Frau Grütters
wie Frau Güler wie Herr Gröhe was ich
aber kritisiere ist die anscheinend
Erweckung als gäbe es ein geschlossenen
Block gegen diese Haltung ich habe schon
in meiner letzten Rede in der ersten
Lesung darauf hingewiesen dass die
größte Landesregierung CDU geführt
ausdrücklich uns auffordern im
Koalitionsvertrag dieses zu machen mit
der Erlassung dem vorarbeitet wir haben
auch das muss man mal sehen die Behörden
unabhängige
asylverfahrensberatung schon pilotiert
unter einem CDU Innenministerium all das
haben Sie selbst schon in ihrer
Sinnlichkeit in seiner Sinnlichkeit
erkannt und jetzt üben sie dagegen
Opposition das Markt verstehen wer will
ich verstehe es nicht
wenn wir in diesen Tagen in dieses Jahr
wieder üblich geworden ist das Thema
Migration komplett zu ideologisieren und
emotionalisieren davon sprechen ich
zitiere jemanden er weiß wie
angesprochen ist dass wir die
Staatsangehörigkeit verramschen würden
dass das die Integration nicht fördern
würde dass wir damit pulleffekte für
illegale Migration auslösen würden zeigt
dass die Person
eben nicht verstanden hat was
Staatsangehörigkeit bedeutet nämlich das
ist ein Kompliment wenn Menschen
deutsche Staatsangehörige werden wollen
das zwar nicht verstanden hat was
integration bedeutet das ist ein
Kompliment für dieses Land das Menschen
hier deutsch lernen hier leben wollen
sich einfügen in dieses Land und nicht
begreifen dass Änderungen im
Aufenthaltsrecht gesetzt oder
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht doch nicht die
Hauptgründe sind warum Menschen sich auf
die Flucht begeben das ist doch ein
Irrsinn und eine vieldeutung die
Realität ist aber das vor meinem Büro
vor nicht langer Zeit lange Haare
bestand und geschildert hat wie er in
diesem Land lange lebt seit sieben
Jahren aus gekommen fast verreckt auf
der Anreise er hat sofort Deutsch
gelernt sein Schriftdeutsch ist besser
als das in jeder Bachelorarbeit er hat
eine Freundin ist verlobt kann aber
nicht heiraten wegen der ungeklärten
Identitätsfrage er hat sich immer Arbeit
gesucht nie von Transferleistung gelebt
er sich sofort am sportver angeschlossen
er möchte mit seiner Freundin am
liebsten mit dem Wohnmobil nach
Frankreich fahren und kämpfen der Mann
ist besser integriert der ist Deutscher
als ich es je sein könnte was für einen
Sinn macht es diese Mann eine Chance in
diesem Land zu verwehren es macht keinen
Sinn und es ist auch eine anscheinend
Erweckung als ob wir ernsthaft ihn und
tausende hunderttausende weitere von ihm
abschieben könnten dann würden wir
unsere ganzen Landes- und Bundespolizei
lahmlegen und wir können es im real,-
akzeptieren wie diesen ist Zustand oder
leben wir in der Fiktion dass er
Perspektive bleiben muss und doch nicht
abgeschoben wird und für mich ist dieser
Entscheidung glasklar es ist eine
Entscheidung des parmatismus der
Vernunft und auch der Menschlichkeit es
zeichnet nämlich eine Gesellschaft nicht
aus ein Wettbewerb zu machen wer am
härtesten und am unmenschlichsten ist
sondern es zeichnet eine Gesellschaft
aus dass sie mit ihrer Gesetzgebung in
ihrer Realität und einer Bevölkerung die
sehr souverän sehr selbstbewusst mit
Migration umgeht endlich gerecht wird
diese Entscheidung haben wir heute vor
der stehen wir sagen sie ja vielen Dank
helen ist Berichterstatter für dieses
Themenfeld bzw für die bei die Gesetze
die hier im später abgestimmt werden
namentliche übrigens und hat die Debatte
begonnen über Änderungen im
Aufenthaltsgesetzes geht um ein
sogenanntes Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht und
es geht auch um beschleunigte
Asylverfahren Andrea Lindholz ist die
nächste Rednerin stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren wir brauchen
in Deutschland eine umsichtige
Asylpolitik und einen Rechtsstaat der
sich ernst nimmt und der keine
Fehlanreize setzt und genau diese
Voraussetzungen erfüllt dieser
Gesetzentwurf nicht ich empfehle hier
auch gerne mal in die Anhörung und die
Stellungnahme der Sachverständigen
hereinzulesen Deutschland gehört seit
Jahren zu den wichtigsten
Aufnahmeländern weltweit nur die Türkei
und Kolumbien beherbergen heute noch
mehr Flüchtlinge als wir und diese
humanitäre Leistung die lässt sich nicht
unbegrenzt ausweiten und genau deshalb
sollten wir uns auch auf die wirklich
schutzberechtigten fokussieren
bei dem Gesetzentwurf geht es um
ausreisepflichtige Ausländer und ja es
gibt Ausnahmen in denen man pragmatische
Lösungen braucht die Ampel tut aber so
als ob ausreisepflichtige Ausländer die
sich gut integriert haben in unserem
Land keine Chance hätten und genau diese
Behauptung ist falsch von den rund
830.000 abgelehnten Asylbewerbern die im
Ausländer Zentralregister registriert
sind haben heute 75 Prozent einen
regulären Aufenthaltstitel und warum ist
das so weil auch wir weil auch mit der
Union in der vergangenen
Legislaturperiode längst pragmatische
Lösungen gefunden worden sind
unser geltendes Aufenthaltsrecht belohnt
gute Integration auch bei
ausreisepflichtigen ein Bleiberecht gibt
es zum Beispiel wenn man ein
qualifizierten Beruf ausübt wenn man
eine Berufsausbildung absolviert hat es
gibt Ausnahmen für gut integrierte
Jugendliche unter 21 für Familien und
gut integrierte Erwachsene
Aussetzung für diese Chance ist dass die
Betroffenen zunächst ehrlich sagen wer
sie sind und woher sie kommen und wie
sie heißen und genau mit diesem Prinzip
will die Ampel jetzt brechen dafür uns
geht erst identitätsklärung dann Chance
und nicht umgekehrt
die Ampel will ausreisepflichtigen
Menschen auch dann ein Aufenthaltsrecht
geben wenn Sie aktiv über ihre Identität
getäuscht oder die Mitwirkung an dieser
identitätsklärung verweigert haben sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen belohnen
damit die falschen sie belohnen
identitäts-
und wer sein Pass verloren hat und wer
keinen Ersatz beschaffen kann und auch
der kann seine Identität schon nach den
jetzt geltenden Regeln mit anderen
Mitteln belegen es ist für uns
entscheidend und für das
gesetzentscheiden der Wille zur
Mitwirkung und sie wollen jetzt die
Personen belohnen die fünf Jahre lang
genau diesen Willen nicht gezeigt haben
und sie nehmen damit den Anreiz an der
identitätsklärung mitzuwirken und das
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist fatal
und mindestens genauso fatal ist ihre
Anhebung der Altersgrenze für
Jugendliche die von auch in der jetzigen
Rechtslage eine Chance haben die
Anhebung der Altersgrenze von 21 auf 27
Jahre obwohl sie genau wissen dass zwei
Drittel aller
unberechtigter Asylbewerber junge Männer
in diesem Alter sind und diese Gruppe
soll von ihnen künftig auch schon nach
drei Jahren ein Bleiberecht erhalten
auch wenn sie nicht schutzbedürftig sind
der Entwurf von Frau Feser hätte sogar
dazu geführt dass man direkt von der
Ablehnung in den legalen Aufenthalt
gerutscht wäre das haben sie in letzter
Minute ja gerade noch gestoppt und
diesen krassen Fehler notdürftig
repariert aber was zeigt uns das das
zeigt uns dass sie an wirklicher und
echter Rückführung nicht interessiert
sind die Ampel und vor allem Dingen die
FDP reden hier seit Monaten von ihrer
rückführungsoffensive fakt ist dass sie
nach einem Jahr noch nicht mal einen
rückführungsbeauftragten benannt haben
ihre Detailregelung zur Abschiebehaft
heute ist nichts anderes als ein
Feigenblatt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
seit September 2021 liegt die Evaluation
des geordneten rückkehrgesetzes dass wir
noch verabschiedet haben vor und die
Länder haben viele Maßnahmen mit diesem
Gesetz begrüßt und weitere neue
Maßnahmen vorgeschlagen fragen Sie sich
mal warum sie keinen einzigen dieser
guten Vorschläge aufgreifen weil sie im
Grunde aus ideologischen Gründen
überhaupt keine Rückführung wollen im
Grunde lehnen Sie sie ab und ihr Gesetz
hier heute hat schon dafür geführt dass
in Baden-Württemberg ein Gericht mit
Verweis auf ihren Gesetzentwurf eine
Rückführung ausgesetzt hat liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie belohnen
die falschen und wir als Union wir
stehen für einen glaubwürdigen
Rechtsstaat wir stehen für eine
Asylpolitik die von Humanität und
Ordnung geprägt ist und das ist auch der
Grund warum wir Ihren Gesetzentwurf hier
und heute ablehnen werden
Andrea Lindholz ist eine der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
cdu/csu-fraktion im Bundestag gesagt
dass wir den Gesetzentwurf ablehnen
werden es gibt allerdings für deutliche
Hinweise darauf dass ein nicht
unerheblicher Teil aus der
Unionsfraktion mehr 20 sollen es
immerhin sein sich bei der Abstimmung
enthalten wollen also nicht gegen
explizit nicht gegen diesen
Gesetzentwurf für der Koalition Stimmen
vieles Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren mit
dem chancenaufenthaltsrecht und der
Verbesserung der bestehenden
Bleiberechtsregelung für gut integrierte
geduldete der Einführung endlich einer
bundesfinanzierten behördenunabhängigen
asylverfahrensberatung der Erleichterung
des Familiennachzugs mit Wegfall des
spracherfordernis vor der Einreise der
Öffnung der Integrationskurse in einem
ersten Schritt und der Abschaffung der
anlasslosen widerrufsprüfung setzen wir
unsere ersten zentralen
flüchtlingspolitischen Vorhaben um für
die wir Grüne lange gekämpft haben das
ist ein Paradigmenwechsel liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
Flüchtlingspolitik
Reformen
die von der Zivilgesellschaft der
Kirchen Herr frei Gewerkschaften und
nicht zuletzt der Wirtschaft seit Jahren
als längst überfällig erachtet wurden
wer daran noch gezweifelt haben sollte
den muss die Sachverständigen Anhörung
zum chancenaufenthaltsrecht gesetzt vom
vergangenen Montag liebe Frau Lindholz
nun wirklich eines Besseren belehrt
haben was schaffen wir mit dieser Reform
wir ziehen die Konsequenz aus
daraus dass die bisherigen
Bleiberechtsregelung aus 16 Jahren
unionsgeführter Innenpolitik ins Leere
gelaufen sind deshalb schaffen wir das
chancenaufenthaltsrecht mehr als
137.000 Menschen sollen vom kommenden
Jahr an aus dem System der
entwürdigenden Kettenbildung geholt
werden und endlich eine Perspektive in
Deutschland bekommen
alle die seit fünf Jahren geduldet oder
gestattete Leben bekommen in dem Chancen
ja ein gesicherten Status um die
Voraussetzung für ein dauerhaftes
Bleiberecht zu erfüllen zu arbeiten wenn
Sie bisher keine Beschäftigungserlaubnis
hatten Sprachkenntnis zu erwerben wo
ihnen bisher der Zugang zum
Integrationskurs verwehrt wurde und sich
Identitätsnachweise zu besorgen so weit
die Herkunftsländer diese überhaupt
Ausstellen von was für Menschen sprechen
wir meine Damen und Herren Beispiele
haben uns Flüchtlingsräte Kirchen in
allen Handwerkskammern Handelskammern
zugeschickt der Junge Eritrea der schon
fünf Jahre in Deutschland gelebt
erfolgreich eine Lehre zum Koch
abgeschlossen hatte und dessen
Arbeitgeber alles tat um eine befristete
aufent Arbeitserlaubnis zu beschaffen am
Ende verhängten die Behörden die
unsägliche Duldung leid um ihm und ihm
wurde eine Beschäftigung dauerhaft
verweigert oder der Afghane seit sieben
Jahren bei uns erfolgreich die aus
Bildung zum Metallbauer abgeschlossen
von seiner Firma übernommen
Sozialbeiträge bezahlt im örtlichen
Fußballverein spielen engagiert in der
Kirchengemeinde den mündlichen
Sprachnachweis packt er aber nicht den
schriftlichen weil er Legastheniker ist
belegt durch Atteste und Gutachten meine
Damen und Herren das ist entwürdigend
und dagegen helfen keine dauerparolen
der Abgrenzung der Diffamierung und der
Spaltung sondern eine Antwort die
Chancen bietet und Perspektiven
letztendlich doch für uns alle eröffnet
daher laden wir Sie herzlich ein
mitzumachen auch in ihren Wahlkreisen
liebe Kolleginnen der Union gibt es
unzählige Betriebe die das alles genauso
sehen und ihnen die Frage stellen werden
warum sie diese Reform abgelehnt haben
warum die junge geduldete aus Hannover
als intensivpflegerin tätig abgeschoben
werden soll
meine Damen und Herren für die
Wirtschaft wieder deutsche Industrie und
handelskammertag oder das Bündnis aus
Unternehmen für ein Bleiberecht aus
Baden-Württemberg ist klar und für uns
auch Ausbildung statt Abschiebung meine
Damen und Herren die Koalition wird das
chancenjahr nun auf 18 Monate nach dem
wichtigen Hinweisen aus der Anhörung
verlängern die Verschiebung des
Stichtags um zehn Monate wird dazu
führen dass mehr Menschen von der
Regelung profitieren können wir werden
außerdem mit den Verbesserungen bei den
bestehenden bleiberechtsregelungen
weitere Möglichkeiten für geduldete
eröffnen beim bisherigen Bleiberecht für
gut integrierte Jugendliche ermöglichen
wir bereits nach drei Jahren für
Familien nach vier Jahren und
alleinstehende Erwachsene nach sechs
Jahren den Spurwechsel zusätzlich zum
chancenaufenthaltsrecht ein gesicherten
Aufenthaltstitel und die ebenfalls lang
geforderte Altersgrenze von 21 Jahren
beim Bleiberecht für gut integrierte
setzen wir auf 27 Jahre auch das ein
ganz wichtiger Beitrag raus aus den
unsäglichen kettenbildungen
mit den Änderungen die wir zu diesem
Gesetz Ihnen heute vorlegen werden wir
auch eine einjährige Vorbildung für
Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene nach
dem Bleiberecht für gut integrierte
einführen wir halten diese
vorbildungsfrist für falsch und tragen
sie aber als Kompromiss mit meine Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen von SPD und
FDP wir sollten aber schon jetzt prüfen
ob nicht alternative Möglichkeiten im
migrationspaket bestehen denn wenn junge
Menschen die sich trotz eines langen
Asylverfahrens gut integriert haben oder
ihren Aufenthaltstitel verloren haben
weil sie ihren eingeschlagenen
Bildungsweg ändern müssen oder mussten
nicht abgeschoben werden sollen müssen
wir das gesetzlich sicherstellen und
nicht über härtefallkommissionen heilen
meine Damen und Herren
abschließend zwei wichtige Punkte zu den
Änderungen im Asylgesetz endlich kommt
sie die gesetzliche Verankerung für eine
flächendeckende behördenunabhängige
verfahrensberatung das wird in jedem
Fall zu einer Qualität der asylbescheide
und außerdem ist eine Rechtsberatung vor
der Anhörung für uns unglaublich wichtig
und auch europarechtlich geboten und
last but not least die Streichung der
anlasslosen widerrufsprüfung positiver
Bescheide des Bundesamtes für Migration
und Flüchtlinge diese Praxis war und ist
ebenso unverhältnismäßig wie aufwendig
beim bambt wurden unzählige Kapazitäten
von Personal gebunden die an anderer
Stelle für die Beschleunigung der
Asylverfahren benötigt werden die
Neuregelung wird eine enorme Entlastung
beim BAM zu einer enorme Entlastung
führen und am Ende möchte ich mich ganz
herzlich bei Ministerium bedanken beim
Innenministerium heute stellvertretend
bei Herrn Özdemir und den Kolleginnen
für die guten Beratung und ich empfehle
dem Hohen Haus die Zustimmung zu diesen
beiden Gesetzen ich bedanke mich für
Ihre und eure Aufmerksamkeit
vieles Polleiter aus der Fraktionen
Bündnis 90 die Grünen mehrheitlich zum
sogenannten Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht zu
diesem Thema aber auch zu den Änderungen
die es in der Asylgesetzgebung geben
soll wird jetzt Bernd Baumann der
nächste Redner sein erster
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die Regierung liegt heute zwei
Gesetzentwürfe vor und hat einen dritten
bereits im Kabinett mit denen will sie
die Einwanderung nach Deutschland noch
leichter machen es sollen noch einfacher
werden ein deutschen Pass zu erhalten in
aktuellen Umfragen lehnt zwei Drittel
der Bevölkerung das ab respektieren Sie
das stoppen Sie diese Politik
hunderttausende Migranten müssten schon
seit Jahren Deutschland verlassen weil
sie ausreisepflichtig sind ihre
Asylgründe sind endgültig abgelehnt weil
sie oft nur vorgetäuscht waren sie alle
will die Ampel jetzt nicht abschieben
sie will jetzt endgültig alle im Land
behalten aus illegalen sollen legale
werden was für eine Verhöhnung des
Rechtsstaats meine Damen und Herren
schlimmer noch
10 tausende Beamte mussten jahrelang an
den Asylverfahren Arbeiten überlastete
Richter Staatsanwälte Polizisten
verbrachten Millionen Arbeitsstunden
damit und jetzt kommt die Linkshänder
links gelbe Regierung und sagt
Interessiert uns alles gar nicht mehr
die Asylanten bleiben alle da was für
eine Verachtung für die Arbeit unserer
Stadt meine Damen und Herren
der neue Kabinettsentwurf der Regierung
geht ja noch weiter ausländer müssen
nicht mehr acht Jahre in Deutschland
gelebt haben bis in den deutschen Pass
kriegen künftig reichen fünf Jahre in
vielen Fällen sogar drei warum so kurze
Fristen weil damit auch die Syrer von
2015 schnell deutsche werden können fast
eine Million dazu die Hunderttausenden
Afghanen Iraker Marokkaner Somalia
Senegalesen alle sollen deutsche werden
der totale ausverkauft das darf doch
nicht sein meine Damen und Herren
um den Migranten die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft noch schmackhafter zu
machen dürfen die sogar den alten Pass
behalten werden doppelstaatlichkeit wird
zur Norm auch für Analphabeten gibt es
neue Regeln für schnelle Einbürgerung
selbst orientalische heiratsverhältnisse
wie zahllosen Ehefrauen sind kein
Hintergrund mehr
sämtliche Gesetze Zielen in die gleiche
Richtung alle dürfen kommen alle dürfen
bleiben deutsche werden was für eine
schreiende Einladung an die ganze Welt
kein anderes Land macht das so meine
Damen und Herren
warum machen sie das es käme Fachkräfte
haben sie gesagt dabei belegen alle
Zahlen das Gegenteil 70 Prozent aller
Syrer fast 70 Prozent Leben von Hartz IV
auch sieben Jahre nach ihrer Ankunft bei
somalian Afghanen oder Ghan ist es
ähnlich dramatisch also warum machen sie
das humanitäre Gründe haben sie gesagt
wir müssen Schutz suchenden helfen für
die Ukraine ist das richtig der flüchten
Frauen und Kinder aber die meisten
Migranten der letzten Jahre kam aus
Orient und Afrika vorwiegend junge
Männer selbst
EU-Kommissarin Johannsen gibt jetzt zu
die große Mehrheit braucht keinen Schutz
sie kommen aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen
wie zum Beispiel fallsal ist der jüngste
in der Presse sagt die ich kam mit zehn
Tagen von Damaskus nach Dresden für
6.500 wörtlich sagt er weiter jeder will
jetzt nach Deutschland wenn er das Geld
für die Schleppe aufbringen kann solche
Leute kommen nach Deutschland sind es
sind allzu oft keine humanitären Gründe
es kommen in der Masse weder Fachkräfte
noch schutzbedürftige aber die
ampelregierung öffnet weiter die
Schleusen gegen den Willen der Deutschen
80 Prozent fordern besseren Grenzschutz
gehen sie darauf ein respektieren sie
das
es bleibt die bohrende Frage warum
machen sie das schon als Abgeordnete
Landesparlament in Hamburg habe ich mich
gewundert als eine grüne Abgeordnete
davon redete dass in einigen Jahren die
Deutschen im eigenen Land in der
Minderheit sein werden und sie ergänzte
wörtlich das ist auch gut so Frau
Göring-Eckardt langjährige
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen hier im
Bundestag sagte während der
Flüchtlingsströme 2015 nicht zitiere
unser Land wird sich ändern und zwar
drastisch ich freue mich darauf und die
Chefin der Grünen Jugend spricht von
einer ich zitiere ekligen weißen
Mehrheitsgesellschaft die sie nicht mehr
will
allein seit 2014 kam über 8 Millionen
Ausländer nach Deutschland die Linken
und Grünen freuen sich darüber für sie
wird hier ein Großprojekt umgesetzt dass
sie herbei sehen eine Transformation hin
zu einer ganz anderen Republik die alles
aufzulösen droht was wir unsere Heimat
nennen meine Damen und Herren
und diese Transformation ist radikaler
als es sich die meisten Bürger überhaupt
vorstellen können und von der ist wenn
sie weitergeht kein Zurück mehr gibt es
ist die Ideologie eine anonymen diversen
Weltgesellschaft eine linke Utopie eine
heilsvorstellung deren Schlagworte
lauten no borders keine Grenzen mehr no
nation keine Nation mehr vor allem keine
deutsche One World mit mehr diversity
also divers alles mit allem vermengt
grenzenlos Bund gemischt alles erreicht
durch Grenzöffnung Migration und
anschließende Quoten zwangsquoten wir
wollen diese große Umgestaltung nicht
dieses linke hirngespinster das wollen
wir nicht und das darf sie in
Deutschland auch nicht geben meine Damen
und Herren dieses links grüne Experiment
einer Regenbogen Weltgesellschaft geht
auch noch ein her mit sprechverboten mit
kenzel culture gegen alle Kritiker
mittlerweile mit Verbündeten in allen
gesellschaftlichen Organisation
in Kirchen und Schulen in Printmedien
und öffentlich-rechtlichen die Parteien
und Parlamenten und jetzt auch noch im
Sport meine Damen und Herren die
deutsche Nationalmannschaft ist mit
stundenlang Diskussion um Regenbogen am
Oberarm zugrunde gegangen wir wollen
nicht dass auch nur die deutsche
Nationen zugrunde geht meine Damen und
Herren
zwei Drittel aller Menschen die
Deutschland sagen zwei Drittel sagen sie
trauen sich nicht mehr offen ihre
Meinung zu sagen uniprofessoren schreien
auf weil sie nicht mehr frei forschen
können Schauspieler und Literaten werden
öffentlich bedrängt sie sollen Haltung
zeigen im Sinne der Ideologie und über
all dem Vätern die Regenbogenflagge und
die steht eben nicht für Rechtsstaat die
steht nicht für Freiheit und
Menschenrechte sie ist das linke Symbol
eine diversen bunten zwangsgesellschaft
für die historische kämpfte Freiheit in
der deutschen Geschichte stehen nicht
die Farben des linken Regenbogens dafür
stehen schwarz rot gold das sind die
Farben von Freiheit und Demokratie das
sind unsere Farben meine Damen und
Herren
Bernd Baumann war das für die
afd-fraktion und das gibt mir Anlass und
Gelegenheit für eine Korrektur bzw
Präzisierung am Freitag vor einer Woche
hat sich die afd-fraktion in einer
Geschäftsordnungsdebatte hier im Plenum
dafür ausgesprochen dass das
bürgergeldgesetz nicht auf die
Tagesordnung kommt das sei so war die
Argumentation der AFD in einer
Sitzungswoche in der der Bundeshaushalt
2023 abschließend beraten werde nicht
angemessen ich habe dazu gesagt dass es
bereits am Vortag also am Donnerstag
Debatten zu anderen Gesetzentwürfen
gegeben habe gegen die die afd-fraktion
ich zitiere mich selbst keinerlei
Einwände gehabt habe das war nur zum
Teil richtig tatsächlich gab es am
Donnerstag keine formellen Einwände
durch die afd-fraktion sie hatte sich
aber bereits am Dienstag dagegen
ausgesprochen dass sie in einer
haushaltswoche andere Gesetzentwürfe
diskutiert oder abgestimmt werden und
für diese Ungenauigkeit bitte ich jetzt
um Entschuldigung Stefan
Impuls wir gehen damit zurück in die
Debatte in der es um Änderungen am
aufent an aufenthaltsgesetzen geht
Stefan Thomi gehört der FDP-Fraktion an
ist einer der Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer
haben wollen obwohl die Gastarbeiter der
Nachkriegsjahre ein normanteil hatten am
Aufbau des deutschen Wirtschaftswunders
und jetzt sind wir wieder in einer
Situation wo viele Arbeitgeber
händeringend nach Arbeitskräften suchen
wenn man sich mit Unternehmern unterhält
dann werden
jedenfalls zwei sorgen immer adressiert
was die Unternehmen in ihrem Fortkommen
und ihren Bestand bedroht das sind
aktuell die hohen Energiepreise das sind
aber seit langer Zeit und sich immer
weiter verschärfend die fehlenden
Arbeitskräfte und deswegen
müssen wir Einwanderung
zu verstehen lernen als als Chance und
aber auch als Notwendigkeit das ist die
eine Wahrheit und die zweite Wahrheit
ist ja nicht alle Menschen die bei uns
Asyl beantragen haben auch einen was sie
validen Asylgrund und nicht alle die
gerne bei uns arbeiten möchten bringen
dafür auch die notwendigen
Voraussetzungen mit und deswegen müssen
wir auf diese beiden Wahrheiten auch
zweifach reagieren wir brauchen eine
wirksame Migrationskontrolle wir
brauchen aber auch eine bessere
Integrationsförderung bei uns im Land
das ist doch kluge Migrationspolitik
beides im Blick zu behalten und deswegen
legen wir heute zwei Gesetzentwürfe vor
die diese beiden Dinge im Blick haben
das erste ist dass die
asylgerichtsverfahren vor allem bei uns
viel zu lange dauern sieht dauern im
Bundesschnitt über 26 Monate das ist zu
lang und das müssen wir natürlich
beschleunigen natürlich gewiss mit der
Behutsamkeit die wir immer brauchen wenn
wir nicht rechtsstaatliche Grundsätze
über Bord werfen wollen und deswegen
gehen wir vorsichtig und behutsam vor
versuchen an verschiedenen Stellen
beschleunigen Schritte zu ergreifen und
wissen natürlich genau das nicht in
einen Knopf gibt wo man den Turbo
einschalten kann wir gehen da behutsam
und Vorsicht und doch wirksam vor wir
entlasten auch des Bundesamt für
Migration und Flüchtlingen weil wir
davon absehen dass künftige jeder
Asylbescheid regelmäßig wieder überprüft
werden soll das bindet beim Bank enorme
Personal der Ressourcen und führt nur in
etwa 5% der Fälle auch zu einer
Korrektur der
asylbescheidet das ist ineffizient und
deswegen wollte ich nur noch
anlassbezogen die asylprüfung vornehmen
und ja ich weiß die einen sehen die
Verlängerungen der Abschiebehaft sehr
kritisch und die anderen sehen die
staatliche Förderung einer
behördenunabhängigen
asylverfahrensberatung sehr kritisch
aber bei der Abschiebehaft gehen wir
doch nur an Straftäter ran und Klammern
die Minderjährigen aus und bei der
asylverfahrensberatung achten wir doch
genau darauf dass wir das Modell der
Schweiz uns genau vor Augen halten wo
auch die Trennung von Beratung und
Entscheidung vorgenommen wird mit viel
Erfolg und keine Angst da wird es
Standards geben wie diese Beratung
stattfinden muss das ist
der eine Gesetzentwurf und der zweite
ist der chancenaufenthalt wir müssen
endlich bei der Integration der Menschen
mehr in die Offensive kommen über
130.000 Menschen in Deutschland sind
seit über fünf Jahren geduldet können
aber nicht abgeschoben werden bekommen
aber auch kein Aufenthaltstitel und ja
hängen im Sozialsystem Fest statt dass
sie in die Welt der Arbeit integriert
werden können da müssen wir doch
Vorankommen dürfen nicht auch die
falschen abzuschieben versuchen wir
müssen die die sich integrieren wollen
integriert sind oder arbeiten wollen
doch arbeiten lassen ist doch ein
Widerspruch einerseits über
Arbeitskräftemangel zu klagen aber nicht
als arbeiten wollen daran zu hindern in
Steinen
deswegen ist unser Chance Aufenthalt ein
Baustein erinnert sich an Menschen die
über fünf Jahre hier sind gute
integriert sind und der Sprache
beherrschen straffrei sind denn
Identität geklärt ist und riesig vor
allem nur an Vorgänge in der
Vergangenheit in Zukunft wollen wir eine
neue Arbeitskräfte Einwanderung
durchsetzen und dafür sind diesen in
dieser Woche auch eine Bier beschlossen
worden insofern beinhaltet unser
navigationspaket beides es schafft
Verbesserung bei der Migrationskontrolle
und Verbesserungen bei der Netzwerke bei
Integrationsförderung und das ist ein
Beispiel für kluge Migrationspolitik
meine Damen und Herren
Stefan thomey FDP-Fraktion der Bundestag
diskutiert über Änderungen meinem
Aufenthaltsgesetz geht um Asylverfahren
ist geht um ein Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
das geduldeten bessere Perspektiven
geben soll in Deutschland dazu jetzt
klarer Bünger aus der Linksfraktion sie
ist Sprecherin für fluchtpolitik
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir stimmen
heute über die ersten beiden asylpakete
der Ampel Koalition ab beide sind aus
meiner Sicht eine riesen Enttäuschung
der Gesetzentwurf zum Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht schafft nicht wirklich
Chancen für die die sie bräuchten und
das asylverfahrensbeschleunigungsgesetz
keine Beschleunigung und ich weiß auch
dass sie sich in der Koalition da nicht
immer einig waren und dass die FDP
teilweise blockiert hat und ich sag's
Ihnen ganz ehrlich mit uns hätte es das
nicht gegeben aber nun zurück zum Thema
der Gesetzentwurf zum
chancenaufenthaltsrecht hat viel zu hohe
Hürden immer noch um kettendungen die
eigentlich versprochen wirksam zu
beenden sogar nach ihren eigenen
Berechnungen werden nur rund 34.000
Personen die Anforderungen erfüllen
gegenüber den 240.000 geduldeten
Menschen in Deutschland leben ist das
nur ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein
die wesentlichen Kritikpunkte von
Verbänden und NGOs hat die Koalition
vollkommen ignoriert so wurde die
identitätsklärung per eidesstattlicher
Versicherung nicht mitgeregelt wodurch
weiterhin Menschen ausgeschlossen werden
die schlicht keine Pässe Friseur
besorgen können und Frau Lindholz es
gibt Menschen die können diese Pässe
einfach nicht besorgen und sie kennen
die Realität einfach nicht und auch der
Stichtag nein und auf der Stichtag wurde
lediglich um ein Dreivierteljahr
verschoben statt gänzlich abgeschafft da
hätten wir uns mehr gewöhnt das ist aus
unserer Sicht nur ein Ausdruck einer
Politik die nur Zwischenlösung schafft
Helge lind hat gesagt dass Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht sei Vernunft und
Pragmatismus wenn sie wirklich
vernünftig und pragmatisch gewesen wären
hätten hätte die Koalition unserem
Gesetzentwurf für ein Bleiberecht vor
der Sommerpause zugestimmt dann hätte es
die vielen Abschiebungen bis jetzt nicht
gegeben
beim Gesetzentwurf zum asyl-prozessrecht
sage ich Ihnen als Juristin ganz ehrlich
das ist eine richtige Katastrophe im
Koalitionsvertrag wurden faire zügige
und rechtssichere Asylverfahren
versprochen stattdessen liefert die
Ampel jetzt eine Ausweitung und
Manifestation des sonderrechts im
Asylbereich viele wissen gar nicht dass
die Rechte von geflüchteten in
Deutschland schon maximal eingeschränkt
sind und das setzt die Bundesregierung
jetzt auch fort und Frau Pollert hat es
ja auch eingesehen und ich wünsche mir
dass sie da wirklich noch mal nach
helfen ich möchte dazu ein Beispiel
nennen worum es geht dass auch Herr
Rechtsanwalt Münch als der
Sachverständiger für den deutschen
Anwaltsverein am Montag in der Anhörung
war genannt hat wird beispielsweise ein
Auto aufgeschleppt steht den Besitzerin
der komplette Instanzenzug offen im
Asylverfahren wo es um Leben und Tod
geht sind die Rechtsmittel dagegen
eingeschränkt und klargefristen verkürzt
Herr Münch nannte ihren Gesetzentwurf
ein experimentellen Ausbau dieses
sonderrechts gegenüber geflüchteten und
ich möchte an dieser Stelle ergänzen
diese Ungleichbehandlung per Gesetz ist
das Gegenteil von einem
Paradigmenwechsel dabei wäre doch die
Abschaffung dieses sonderrechts
gegenüber geflüchteten der erste und
wichtige Schritt für eine
Gleichberechtigung das haben auch viele
Sachverständigen bestätigt ein
regelrechter Tabubruch hingegen ist die
Ermöglichung von asylanhörung mit
Videotechnik die Anhörung ist das
Kernstück im Asylverfahren dort müssen
geflüchtete ihr Schicksal und häufig
traumatisierende Erlebnisse und
gewaltserfahrung berichten das ist über
eine Kamera einfach nicht möglich weil
es keine vertrauensvolle Atmosphäre
schafft und außerdem sehe ich die Gefahr
dass Sie hier eine Technik
führen die am Ende in Schnellverfahren
in Haftzentren an den EU-Außengrenzen
zum Einsatz kommt womit das Leid dort
noch vergrößert wird diese Verschärfung
lehnen wir natürlich ab und beim Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht müssen wir uns
entscheiden aber müssen wir uns
enthalten aus den genannten Gründen
vielen Dank klar Dünger war das für die
Linksfraktion und ihr wird jetzt folgen
in dieser Debatte Gülistan Yüksel aus
der SPD-Fraktion die haben wir gestern
schon hier gesehen dieses Mitglied im
Innenausschuss und auch
Berichterstatterin ihrer Fraktion zu
diesem Thema gestern hat sie eine sehr
teilweise sehr persönliche Rede gehalten
zum Thema Einbürgerung als das hier in
der Aktuellen Stunde diskutiert worden
ist
kann auf den Tribünen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
ich wünsche mir dass wir zusammenhalten
einander wertschätzen und respektieren
diese Worte
diese Worte stammen von einer Schülerin
aus meinem Wahlkreis die die für ihr
beeindruckendes Engagement für ihren
Einsatz für Integration in unserer Stadt
geehrt wurde
2015 Flo sie als 13-Jährige mit ihrer
Mutter und ihren Geschwistern aus Syrien
fand bei uns ein neues Zuhause und
engagierte engagiert sich auch heute für
die Menschen die Hilfe benötigen und ich
finde liebe Kollegen Kollegen dieser
Wunsch nach Zusammenhalt Wertschätzung
und Respekt Sonntag uns leiten wenn wir
hier über Migration und Integration
debattieren
einen ersten Schritt nehmen wir heute
mit den beiden vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwürfen zum einen
beschleunigen wir dazu die derzeit
langen asylgerichtsverfahren und
vereinheitlichen die Rechtsprechung zum
anderen setzen wir die kettendungen
eines chancenaufenthaltsrechts entgegen
wir geben Menschen die bei uns ihren
Lebensmittelpunkt gefunden haben und
seit vielen Jahren hier leben so eine
aufenthaltsrechtliche Perspektive für
die Betroffenen bedeutet beides mehr
Wertschätzung und Respekt und für die
Gesellschaft mehr Zusammenhalt
damit eine Gesellschaft zusammenhält
müssen wir auch Integration ermöglichen
von Anfang an deshalb ist es gut dass
wir mit dem Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
auch mehr Menschen den Zugang zu
Integrationskursen und Berufs-
nicht zuletzt wird auch Deutschland ganz
konkret davon profitieren denn wir
brauchen Menschen die bei uns leben sich
hier engagieren und arbeiten wollen wir
können uns nicht leisten auf Fach und
Arbeitskräfte zu verzichten schon gar
nicht auf die Arbeitskraft derer die
schon bei uns sind und deshalb ist es
gut dass wir bewährte Regelungen aus dem
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz
entfristen und das zu Fachkräfte
nachziehende Familienangehörige künftig
keinen Sprachnachweis mehr erbringen
müssen es sollte jedem klar sein die
Sprache eines Landes lernt man am
einfachsten vor Ort und nicht wenn man
zum Teil hunderte Kilometer vom
prüfungs-
deshalb kann das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht an dieser Stelle nur
ein erster Schritt sein
seit Jahren erreichen mich Zuschriften
von Menschen die aufgrund des
sprachnachweises von ihren Ehepartnern
und oder ihrer Ehepartnerin getrennt
leben müssen und das teilweise jahrelang
ich glaube niemand hier im Raum möchte
das selbst durchleben darum sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren werden wir in unserem
nächsten Gesetzespaket den
Sprachnachweis für Ehegatten nach so
grundsätzlich erleichtern
zum Ende möchte ich noch kurz an die
Kollegen und Kollegen der Union wenden
ja von den Todes ich sehe sie können das
gar nicht ertragen wenn wir hier vorne
über Integration Migration reden okay
dass sie sich den Realitäten in diesem
Land verweigern ist ja nichts neues das
haben wir ja auch gestern bei der
Debatte zum Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
gesehen aber es ist einfach unerträglich
wie sie dies immer wieder auf den Rücken
derjenigen austragen die besonders
Unterstützung und Hilfe benötigen
seine
seines beziehen die vom Bürgergeld das
haben wir gesehen oder wie hier Menschen
mit Migrationsgeschichte aber anstatt
wie sie den Kopf in den Sand zu stecken
entdecken wir als Ampel die Realitäten
an wie gehen voran und
das ist gut für unser Land und das ist
gut für die Menschen die hier leben sie
können entweder weiter Sandkörner zählen
oder sie arbeiten mit daran dass wir in
einem Land leben in dem die Menschen
zusammenhalten aneinander wertschätzen
und respektieren ich würde mehr
letzteres wünschen herzlichen Dank
aus der SPD-Fraktion in der Debatte über
das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht über
Asylverfahren und in dieser Debatte wird
jetzt sprechen sie gelaunert aus der
Unionsfraktion präziser aus der CSU
Landesgruppe
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
Neustart in der Migrationspolitik modern
ist Einwanderungsrecht
Integrationspolitik der Zukunft das sind
wirklich sehr schöne Worte mit der Sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
ampelregierung des
chancenaufenthaltsrecht bezeichnen aber
es geht nicht darum ob etwas modern toll
neue schön formuliert ist es geht bei
der Migrationspolitik darum ob es von
Verantwortungsbewusstsein geleitet ist
und von Weitblick ob die Folgen
analysiert und nicht nur die
unmittelbaren jetzt folgen sondern auch
die über Jahre mit all den damit
zusammenhängenden Aspekten auch im
Zusammenhang mit wohnungssituationen im
Zusammenhang mit Kosten und so weiter
auch mit der Wirtschaft alles muss genau
analysiert werden und das in dieser
ausreichen und Prüfung habe ich an
diesem Gesetz hier nicht ansatzweise
feststellen können
ihr Gesetz ist und wir reden hier nicht
über das Einwanderer wir reden nicht
über die fachkräfteeinwanderung da haben
sie ja auch einen eigenen Wurf wir reden
hier nicht über die
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht da hatten wir
gestern schon eine Debatte wir reden
über die die aus der ganzen Welt zu uns
kommen verständlicherweise eine Chance
wollen Asyl sagen allerdings abgelehnt
werden und abschieben müssen über die
reden wir und für diese Gruppe ist in
diesem einen 104c letztlich nichts
anderes drin wie ein Amnestiegesetz es
sagt ganz klar die rechts und treuen die
ihre Identität lange verschleiert haben
zum Teil sogar getäuscht haben die
profitieren das war die Anhörung schade
dass sie nicht in der Anhörung waren der
Sachverständige hat es ganz klar
ausgeführt wer von diesen 140 profitiert
die die lange getäuscht haben und oder
lange nicht aktiv mitgewirkt haben weil
für viele für die anderen gibt es schon
ganz ganz viele die SPD hat alles
vergessen was sie die letzten Perioden
gemacht hat von ausbildungsbe
bewegungsduldung wir haben im 25.5 nach
18 Monate Duldung mit einer nichts dafür
kann dass er nicht abgeschoben wird auch
danach 18 Monate ein Aufenthaltsrecht es
gibt schon mehr als man glaubt lassen
Sie mich kurz des
Bundesverfassungsgericht zitieren eine
Rechtsordnung die sich ernst nimmt darf
nicht Prämien auf die Missachtung ihrer
selbst setzen sie schafft sonst Anreize
zur Rechtsverletzung diskriminiert
rechtsstreues Verhalten und untergräbt
damit die Voraussetzungen ihre eigenen
Wirksamkeit kurz die ehrliche darf nicht
der Dumme sein auch diese Vorgabe des
Bundesverfassungsgericht müssen sie
beachten wir müssen irgendwo glaubwürdig
bleiben obwohl wir auch viele Chancen
geben wollen
die weitreichendsten Folgen des wurde
auch in der Anhörung deutlich haben wir
allerdings im 25A und B und sowohl die
vielen beispielfällig kann sie gar nicht
mehr alle hören ja oder diese vielen
vielen ja und alles super toll in die
Kritik können übrigens meistens schon
bleiben die können schon bleiben für die
sind ja dankbar sie haben Recht unsere
Arbeitsmarkt braucht die aber der 25 A
und B sagt genau das nicht da hätte ich
mir von der FDP wahrlich mehr erwartet
in der Anhörung ganz klar drei Jahre
hier bis 27 heranwachsen sind jetzt in
dieser Ampel plötzlich bis 27 im
Strafrecht bis 21 Wellen ab 16 aber nee
wenn alle kommen dürfen bis 27 3 Jahre
zur Schule das wurde ihnen um die Ohren
geflogen in der Anhörungen haben sie
versucht etwas abzuschwächen mit der 12
Monaten ändert aber nichts drei Jahre
hier zur Schule gegangen Verfahren sie
wissen alle wie lange es dauert 12
Monate nicht abgeschoben heißt nach drei
Jahren dauerhaftes Aufenthaltsrecht in
Deutschland wenn das keine Signalwirkung
haben soll also bitte dann haben wir 25b
da haben sie auf diesen 12 Monate
Vorbildungen gleich ganz verzichtet also
mit Kind vier Jahre in Deutschland wenn
sie es dann schaffen A2 und dann 600
Euro Job zu haben dauerhaft ist
aufhaltsrecht in Deutschland wirklich
das sind Signale das muss man doch sehen
das wird eine Auswirkung haben und das
gerade in der aktuellen Zeit wo die
Bürger
Meisterin sein verantwortung heißt
Humanität aber auch mit den Ressourcen
vernünftig umgehen wir wollen denen
helfen die wirklich Hilfe brauchen aber
wir können nicht die ganze Welt einladen
schöne Worte hört sich toll an Marketing
perfekt aber im Ergebnis ist es nicht
gut geworden
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen katrin
Göring-Eckardt
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen ja ich
mute Ihnen auch noch einen Einzelfall zu
Samuel D nämlich lebt seit zwölf Jahren
in Deutschland erarbeitete jahrelang für
die DHL und stand auf eigenen Beinen als
er aus seinem Herkunftsland Äthiopien
endlich ein Pass bekam endet seinen
Alltag abrupt statt der in Aussicht
gestellten Aufenthaltserlaubnis
Verbot eben die bayerische
Ausländerbehörde weiter zu arbeiten und
den Zug ihm seine Duldung jetzt droht
ihm
die Abschiebung lächerliche Einzelfälle
meine Damen und Herren Herr Baumann das
ist ein Mensch der
ein unfallmann
und dieser
sah übrigens auch leider deswegen Pech
gehabt weil er in Bayern lebt ein paar
Kilometer weiter in Thüringen nämlich
hätte man Anfang des Jahres entschieden
dass man auch das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht wartet und ihm weiter
ermöglicht hier bei uns zu arbeiten und
auf eigenen Beinen zu stehen meine Damen
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen mit dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht entscheiden wir
uns für die Wirklichkeit und ja das ist
ein Signal so wie beim
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht wir passen die
Gesetze der
Einwanderungsgesellschaft an darum geht
es anzukommen im Hier und Heute sie
haben gerade in diesen letzten Wochen
meine Damen und Herren von der Union das
Gegenteil versucht sie haben versucht
nach dem Motto was wir in den 80ern und
90er und 2000er Jahren falsch gemacht
haben das machen wir jetzt noch mal
falsch aber aus ein paar Mal falsch wird
nicht richtig sondern es bleibt falsch
was wir brauchen ist ein
Einwanderungsrecht ein Asylrecht und ein
Straßenrecht was der Wirklichkeit dem
Hier und Heute für unser Land gerecht
wird meine Damen und Herren
und vielleicht
vielleicht glauben Sie ja dass sie damit
die Identitätskrise in den eigenen
Reihen irgendwie bewältigen können aber
es geht doch hier um unser Land es sagen
Ihnen ja die eigenen Leute der Kaiser
ist gerade nackt und deswegen brauchen
wir klare und deutliche Antworten
deswegen brauchen wir antworten die
wirtschaftlich vernünftig sind das haben
ganz viele schon gesagt gestern und
heute und ich verstehe es nicht ich
verstehe es auch heute morgen noch nicht
wie sie die ganze Zeit Signale aussetzen
können nach dem Motto das ist uns egal
was die Unternehmen sagen sie sind egal
was die Unternehmen brauchen mir könnte
es egal sein dass Sie das sagen aber
ehrlich gesagt sie arbeiten daran dass
der Ruf Deutschlands in der Welt für all
diejenigen die sagen wir könnten nach
Deutschland gehen und unser Glück dort
versuchen die wir brauchen dass der
nicht nur beschädigt wird sondern hier
dann gehen wir lieber woanders hin
woanders sind anders können wir arbeiten
woanders können wir zum Wohlstand
beitragen und das ist das Problem dass
sie haben aber dass sie in diesem Land
auch machen meine dam
lassen Sie eine Frage Frau aus der
afd-fraktion von Frauen
es gibt nämlich noch was zweites was
mich noch mehr verwundert das sind
Menschen die haben sich für unser Land
entschieden die finden das gut hier die
finden gut was wir hier machen und
deswegen sagen sie wir wollen Teil davon
sein wir wollen Teil des demokratischen
Gemeinwesens sein die Arbeiten hier
ehrenamtlich und kümmern sich um andere
das sind Leute die tragen zum Wohlstand
unseres Landes bei und denen zu sagen
ach nee eigentlich lieber nicht statt zu
sagen ja herzlich willkommen und vielen
Dank dass ihr zu unserem Wohlstand
Beitrag in wollt das wäre doch das
Signal was wir aussenden sollten als
Land und genau das machen wir mit dem
Gesetz heute und hier meine Damen und
Herren
und
wenn sie die Unternehmen anschauen zwei
von dreien sagen ja es ist gut dass wir
geflüchtete beschäftigen wenn Sie die
Unternehmen anschauen dann sagen die ja
das führt zu einem positiven
Betriebsklima das sind Leute die sich
mehr anstrengen als viele andere und
deswegen anders als viele Kritikerinnen
und Kritiker behaupten auch noch mal
klar gesagt es geht nicht darum dass
Leute jahrelang abwarten sondern die
Motivation steigt hier Dinge zu tun die
geflüchteten Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter stehen verdammt hoch im Kurs
bei dem Unternehmen beim Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht geht es um pragmatische
und zeitgemäße Lösungen und es geht
darum wie wir den Menschen
entgegentreten die sich hier etwas
aufbauen wollen die hier gemeinsam mit
uns etwas aufbauen wollen die Frage ist
machen wir es ihnen schwer oder haben
wir das gleiche Ziel vor Augen gemeinsam
Deutschland
mit einem chancenland zu machen wir
entscheiden uns dafür dass wir ein Land
der Chancen sein wollen und ich sage die
Einladung steht dass heute hier ist erst
der Anfang die Einladung steht an Sie
meine Damen und Herren und nach gestern
Abend muss man vielleicht sagen lassen
Sie uns doch lieber Weltmeister der
Chancen werden dieses Land und seine
Menschen haben es verdient
katrin Göring-Eckardt für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen nächster Redner in
dieser Debatte wird Robert Vahle sein
der vor knapp drei Monaten aus der
afd-fraktion ausgetreten ist der Spiegel
berichtete der Grund sei
seine halt die Haltung der Fraktion zu
Russland sei zu kritisch und es gäbe zu
viel Anti Russland Hetze in der Fraktion
haben wir im Spiegel gefunden zu
robertale jetzt ist der fraktionslos
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren immer mehr
Menschen leben in unserem Land
seit 2014 viel weniger Deutsche und viel
mehr Ausländer Bildzeitung von 30.11 22
nach offiziellen Angaben leben derzeit
12,8 Millionen Ausländer bei uns
2015 wanderten ca doppelt so viele bei
uns ein wie neue Kinder geboren wurden
in westdeutschen Großstädten sind junge
Deutsche bereits in der Minderheit kein
Wunder dass das Bildungsniveau ja für ja
beständig absinkt
Fazit der konnte noch nicht mal Deutsch
können der kontinuierliche Multikulti
Bevölkerungsaustausch ist also Tatsache
und er ist kein Zufall das ist die
praktische Umsetzung des
migrationspaktes der Agenda 2030 die von
allen Regierungsparteien konsequent
umgesetzt wird ziel dieser Agenda ist
ein globaler Arbeitsmarkt dazu sollen
traditionelle Gesellschaftsstrukturen in
unserem Land beseitigt werden ich mache
niemandem einen Vorwurf kein Patriot zu
sein oder wie Robert mit Vaterlands
Liebe Zitat zum Kotzen zu finden aber
man muss den Selbstbetrug beenden und
damit Schluss machen den Wählern den
Bevölkerungsaustausch mit Begriffen wie
Bereicherung Integration oder
fachkräftezuwanderung schmackhaft zu
machen erstens können sich Mehrheiten
nicht in Minderheiten integrieren
zweitens werden wir dadurch nicht
bereichert sondern Gesang insgesamt
verarmen weil der Großteil der zu uns
strömenden geringer qualifizierten
dauerhaft in der sozialen Hängematte
verbleibt die Arbeiten nämlich
überwiegen nicht und drittens
hochqualifizierte Fachkräfte machen um
unser Land einen großen Bogen genau aus
demselben Grund weshalb jährlich immer
mehr gut ausgebildete deutsche
auswandern sie haben keine Lust sich für
die dümmste Energie und
Einwanderungspolitik der Welt über die
hohen Steuern und Sozialabgaben
ausplündern zu lassen
ihre Vorhaben sind verfassungswidrig sie
schaffen sich ein neues Staatsvolk nur
um ein paar mehr Wählerstimmen
zugrundeln weil sie fürchten abgewählt
zu werden was die logische Konsequenz
ihrer Politik ist vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das lassen wir jetzt mal so stehen
nächster Redner ist Mohan hat aus der
FDP-Fraktion
was war das bitte
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidenten sehr
geehrter Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
haben im Aufenthaltsrecht mit den
kettendungen ein Durcheinander gehabt
dass dringend geordnet werden Muster es
ist doch absurd dass Menschen die länger
als fünf Jahre bei uns geduldet werden
vom Arbeitsmarkt ferngehalten werden und
das obwohl sie arbeiten können und
wollen
währenddessen sucht die Wirtschaft
Händeringen Mitarbeiter und
Auszubildender und der Staat wir alle
haben kein Interesse daran diesen dieser
Menschen in Transferleistungen zu halten
das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht gibt mehr
als 130.000 Menschen in diesem Land eine
Zukunft und eine Perspektive meine Damen
und Herren
wir sagen klar wenn jemand zum Stichtag
31.10 seit fünf Jahren wurde länger hier
in Deutschland geduldet ist wenn er
straffrei ist dann hat er jetzt drei
Jahre Zeit um den Chancen aufeinander zu
beantragen dann geben wir diesen
Menschen 18 Monate lang die Chance und
die Kriterien für einen Aufenthaltstitel
zu erfüllen das bedeutet Identität geht
nachweisen dass bedeutet Sprache das
bedeutet Job das bedeutet
selbstverständlich auch sauber bleiben
aber wenn
aber wenn dieser Voraussetzungen erfüllt
sind dann sind diese Menschen hier
willkommen dann sollen sie raus aus dem
Aufenthalts Limbo und einen
Aufenthaltstitel haben dann sollen sie
hier verlässlich ihr Leben gestalten und
planen können kurz wir sagen strengt
euch an dann lohnt es sich auch und das
ist auch der richtige Weg das ist das
richtige Angebot meine Damen und Herren
aber dazu gehört genauso klar dass
Signal Straftäter Gefährder Menschen die
bewusst täuschen und Tricks sind müssen
verlässlich ausreisen Menschen die
unsere Grundgesetz nicht achten oder
sogar verachten haben bei uns keinen
Platz und auch kein Schanzen Aufenthalt
deswegen ist es auch richtig dass wir
zum Beispiel die abschieberhaft
verlängern so ermöglichen wir
Abschiebung konsequenter als vorher denn
deshalb denn das sorgt erstens für
Akzeptanz bei der Menschen im Land die
zurecht erwarten dass wir für Sicherheit
sorgen und recht auch durchsetzen es
sorgt zweitens aber auch dafür dass die
große Mehrheit der ehrlichen gedulden
Menschen sieht die halten Wort und das
tun wir meine Damen und Herren wir
halten Wort bei den Ausweisen wie bei
der ausgestreckten Mann
meine Damen und Herren der Union noch
für mich als Mitbürger mit
migrationsvordergrund sie wissen ja ich
komme aus Niederbayern
ist dieses Gesetz
ebenso wie das Gesetz zu beschleunigten
Asylverfahren der Beginn eine
aufmunternden Antwort an den ehemaligen
Innenminister Horst Seehofer der die
Migration als Mutter aller Probleme
bezeichnet hatte
und meine Antwort darauf wenn ein Junge
wie ich aus dem Irak hierher kommen und
sich integrieren kann und dann heute als
Bürger dieses Landes dass ich meine
Heimat nenne hier stehen kann dann ist
das kein Problem meine Damen und Herren
aber was ich dafür brauchte waren
Chancen und diese Chancen hier und heute
so vielen anderen zu ermöglichen das
macht mich stolz sehr stolz vielen Dank
Mohammad alhanak aus der FDP-Fraktion am
Ende auch noch mit ein zwei persönlichen
Sätzen zu seiner Biografie es geht hier
um das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht dass die
Ampelkoalition eingebracht hat es geht
um beschleunigte effizientere
Asylverfahren es geht also im großen und
ganzen um das Thema Migration und
Einwanderung und es redet dazu Alexander
throm der innenpolitische Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Deutschland
erbringt wahrlich seit Jahren eine große
humanitäre Leistung bei der Aufnahme von
schutzberechtigten das zeigt sich gerade
auch in diesem Jahr da können wir alle
zu Recht darauf stolz sein es galt aber
immer auch wer keinen Schutz braucht der
hat in letzter Konsequenz unser Land
auch wieder zu verlassen das ist die
Balance zwischen Humanität und Ordnung
auf der anderen Seite und trotzdem gab
es auch bis heute schon viele
Möglichkeiten für ausreisepflichtigen
wenn Sie rechts treu waren wenn sie
Integrationsbereitschaft gezeigt haben
insbesondere auch gearbeitet haben hier
ein Daueraufenthaltsrecht zu erhalten
nur sie Frau Kollegin Göring-Eckardt
sich nicht persönlich aber die Ampel
insbesondere sie reduzieren die
Anforderungen an diese
integrationsvoraussetzungen und damit
bringen sie die Balance in unserem
System zwischen Qualität und Ordnung in
Schieflage
denn erstmals erstmals in der Geschichte
wird ein Aufenthaltsrecht gewährt für
Personen ohne geklärte in die Identität
und die Klärung der eigenen Identität
ist das mindeste was wir von Menschen
erwarten können wenn Sie hier bei uns
bleiben wollen und das machen sie
deshalb weil nur diese Personengruppe
von geduldeten ihr sogenannte
chancenaufenthaltsrecht überhaupt
braucht sie braucht nämlich den
Abschiebeschutz von ein beziehungsweise
jetzt 1,5 Jahren um ihre Identität
offenbaren zu können und oh Wunder
sofern sie das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
von Ihnen bekommen haben den Chancen den
Abschiebeschutz dann werden sie ihre
Identität offenbaren und das ist nicht
in Ordnung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und Herr Kollege Thome wenn Sie das
jetzt mit Arbeitsmigration fachkräftiger
begründen wollen dann reden sie an der
geltenden Rechtslage vorbei auch
geduldete haben heute nach Gelder
Rechtslage grundsätzlich die Möglichkeit
eine Arbeitserlaubnis zu erhalten mit
Ausnahme der Personengruppe
die nicht an ihre gebetserklärung
soutbarer Weise mitwirken und diejenigen
aus sicheren Herkunftsländern des heben
Sie aber auch noch auf insofern ist dass
ihr Gesetz nichts Neues für den
Arbeitsmarkt es sei denn sie nehmen
damit nur die Personen mit ungeklärter
Identität hinein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und jetzt haben sie
auch das Alter beispielsweise bei gut
integrierten Jugendlichen auf bis zur
Vollendung des 27 lebensjahres erhöht
wir wissen zwei Drittel aller
Asylbewerber die kommen sind Männer
damit nichts zu tun aber vor allem sind
sie genau in dieser Altersgruppe und
deswegen habe ich den Herrn
Staatssekretär Satow am 9.11 bei der
Fragestunde gefragt wie denn die
rechtsfolgenabschätzung der Ampel
aussieht mit wie vielen Menschen man den
Rechner die zukünftig über dieses
Institut bis 27 hier ein
Daueraufenthaltsrecht bekommen können
Herr Saathoff sagte jede Prognose ist
mit unweiten verbunden und jede Aussage
darüber wäre nicht zu verantworten wie
können sie es dann verantworten hier ein
Gesetz zu machen von dem sie offenkundig
selbst nicht wissen welche Rechtsfolge
haben will
dann haben Sie das Problem erkannt wenn
Sie die Aufenthaltszeiten verkürzen auf
sechs vier oder gar drei Jahre dass dann
nämlich der Übergang vom asyl- und
Klageverfahren von der Gestattung quasi
in das Daueraufenthaltsrecht nahtlos
funktioniert in aller Regel mit wenigen
mit wenigen Monaten ich komme genau
darauf mit wenigen Monaten
gegebenenfalls und das deshalb der
Rechtsanspruch des Staates auch eine
Ausreisepflicht mal durchzusetzen gar
nicht mehr möglich ist haben Sie erkannt
sind die auf die Kritik eingegangen wir
machen jetzt eine vorbildungszeit von 12
Monaten das heißt in diesen 12 Monaten
kann bei den Jugendlichen bis 27
grundsätzlich noch eine Abschiebung
stattfinden
das führt aber zu dem absurden Ergebnis
dass ein gut integrierter Jugendlicher
der die Schule besucht hat den Abschluss
hat der Deutsch kann der rechtsstreu ist
weil er nämlich seine Identität geklärt
hat in diesen zwölf Monaten abgeschoben
werden kann der rechts und treu der
seine Identität nicht offenbart hat
erhält von ihnen über die
chancenaufenthaltsrecht Abschiebeschutz
und kann nicht abgeschoben werden und
zwar kein einziger Tag seit seinem
Aufenthalt hier in Deutschland das ist
das wurde Ergebnis ihres Gesetzentwurfs
ihres Änderungsantrages des heutigen Tag
und Frau Polat ich kann sie insofern
verstehen dass sie dieser
fortbildungszeit nicht zustimmen wollten
darum gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage
der Kollege
sehr geehrte Frau Präsident vielen Dank
Herr Kollege
noch nicht wirklich drauf erwiesen dass
es offensichtlich der Arbeitsmarkt nicht
funktioniert denn es stehen ja es gibt
2,5 Millionen Arbeitslose den stehen 1,5
Millionen offene Stellen gegenüber warum
haben Sie denn das Problem in den Jahren
während ihrer Regierung eigentlich nicht
gelöst zweitens was ist denn ihr
konkreter Vorschlag beispielsweise der
wiederum eine Modernisierung der
zuwanderungsregeln wie sie wie sie hier
ja planen und vorstellen überflüssig
machen würde ich würde bin sehr gespannt
auf Ihre Ideen und vielleicht erklären
sie noch mal kurz warum sie gerade auf
junge Männer verwiesen haben ihre
Kolleginnen gerade übrigens auch was hat
diese Sachverhalt mit jungen Männern zu
tun
liebe Frau Kollegin ich habe darauf
hingewiesen dass eben in dieser
Altersgruppe überwiegend Männer kommen
habe aber selbst gleich gesagt dass das
mit diesem Gesetz jetzt nichts zu tun
hat das weil das die Statistik ist dass
sie sagt zwei Drittel Männer und bis zum
Alter von 27 bzw 29 Jahren und was denn
Arbeitsmarkt anbelangt was den
Arbeitsmarkt anbelangt habe ich ja
gerade darauf hingewiesen die meisten
geduldeten könnten heute schon Arbeiten
eine Arbeitserlaubnis erhalten
sie arbeiten nun nicht sie sind 27.000
27000 geduldete die tatsächlichen
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
Arbeitsverhältnis sind und unsere
Lösungsvorschlag den sehen Sie im
Paragraph 60B Aufenthaltsgesetz das
sogenannten Duldung leid die wir
seinerzeit gemeinsam mit unserem
Koalitionspartner der SPD in einem
Kompromiss eingeführt haben weil wir
damals beide gemeinsam der Auffassung
waren dass wir alles von den Menschen
zumutbare erwarten können an ihre
identitäts-beschaffung und dann auch
natürlich eine Arbeitserlaubnis gegeben
werden kann solange es nicht passiert
ist besteht keine Arbeitserlaubnis das
handelt sich aber es handelt sich aber
genau um diese Personengruppe ohne
geklärte Identität und das ist auch
richtig dass wir nur die belohnen die
auch tatsächlich rechtsfrei sind liebe
Kollegen Kollegen und sie die Ampel
wollen genau diese Lösung
zum nächsten migrationspaket abschaffen
Vertrauen lassen sie noch eine Frage von
Kollegen thummär aus der FDP-Fraktion zu
natürlich sehr gerne
[Musik]
vielen Frage zulassen ich habe den
Widerspruch den ich aufgezeigt haben
vernommen glaube aber das ist ein
scheinwiderspruch ist denn bei den
Personen die sie als sie rechtsstreuung
Erwachsenen darstellen die besser
gestellt werden als sie rechts untreuen
jungen Erwachsenen haben sich um solche
die schon mehr als fünf Jahre im Inland
sich befinden das ist ja der Clou des
das 140 das Chancen Aufenthaltes
behandelt einen in der Vergangenheit
abgeschlossenen Vorgang deswegen war es
hier schon möglich diese Menschen fünf
Jahre abzuschieben aber nicht noch mal
ein Jahr werden wir bei dem bei dem
anderen bei anderen Personengruppe noch
ein Jahr brauchen um die Abschiebung
durchzuführen
danke für die Frage weil es gibt mir die
Gelegenheit noch ein paar Erklärungen zu
machen sie haben jetzt den Stichtag
angesprochen weil sie gesagt haben dass
es nach hinten wirkt nur wissen Sie was
ein Stichtag eigentlich bedeutet der
bedeutet dass man eigentlich weiß dass
man eigentlich weiß als Gesetzgeber das
etwas macht was eigentlich falsch ist
und deswegen will man sich schützen vor
den weiteren Wirkungen dieses Stichtages
an diese dieser dieses Gesetzes durch
einen Stichtag das ist ja so sie wollen
ja Nachahmer
vermeiden die sich dann auf dieses
Gesetz berufen können also erkennen sie
dass etwas falsch ist das Problem bei
diesen Stichtagen Fristen und wie auch
immer in der Gesetzgebung bei uns ganz
genauso wie bei Ihnen das zukünftig sein
werden sie werden meistens aufgehören
infrastruktung daraus gemacht und
dadurch dass sie die Frist jetzt schon
verlängert haben zum 31.10 dieses Jahres
zeigen sie genau dass sie auch hier an
dem Stichtag weiter drehen werden dann
Herr Kollege Thomas
sie haben ja sie haben ja gefragt nach
dem Widerspruch bei 104c zwischen den
Jugendlichen die wenn sie gut integriert
sind in diesen zwölf Monaten
vorbildungszeit abgeschoben werden
können und den sogenannten Erwachsenen
also denen sonstigen jedenfalls nicht
unter 25A Aufenthaltsgesetz fallen nein
da haben sie die Situation nicht richtig
erkannt und sie es geht auch um die
Frage nicht wann nach wie viel Jahren
jemand abgeschoben werden kann nach drei
oder nach fünf Jahren sondern es geht um
die Frage dass sie ein Gesetz machen bei
dem der rechtsstreue Jugendliche bis 21
27 Jahren der eine Schule besucht hat
ein Abschluss gemacht hat deutsch
spricht bestens integriert ist die wir
auch hier behalten wollen jedenfalls ist
21 Jahren dass dieser nach ihrem
Änderungsantrag über diese 12 Monate
vorbildungszeit abgeschoben werden kann
der rechts und Treue von mir aus zwei
Jahr länger da ist fünf Jahre der rechts
und Treue der nicht gut integriert ist
weil er seine Identität nicht geklärt
hat und wer seine Identität nicht
offenbart kann per se schon nicht mehr
Gesetzes wegen Definition gut integriert
sein dieser dieser rechts und Treue
erhält von ihnen über die Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht quasi einen
Abschiebeschutz nicht ein Tag in der
Zeit in der sich in Deutschland befindet
kann er abgeschoben werden und das ist
der Widerspruch und das ist der Burg in
ihrer Gesetzgebung Herr Kollege
und jetzt
also liebe Kollegin zweite rede ich
bedanke mich grundsätzlich euch immer
für jede Zwischenfrage Herr Kollege
rückführungsoffensive Vergangenheit
bereinigen sie die Statistik für die
Zukunft großzügige bleiberechte und für
die Problemfälle schaffen sie im
nächsten migrationspaket die alte
stadtliche Erklärung zu
identitätsklärung es bleiben zum Schluss
wirklich nur noch die Straftäter übrig
die abgeschoben werden kann ihr
rückführungsoffensive die der FDP so
wichtig ist ist ein reiner
Etikettenschwindel und deswegen gehen
wir das Gesetz heute ab herzlichen Dank
Alexander Thomas ist ja in politische
Sprecher der Unionsfraktion hat jetzt
auch am Ende noch mal gesagt deshalb
lehnen wir dieses Gesetz heute ab das
hat im Vorfeld die Meldung gegeben
beispielsweise von Robin Alexander von
der Welt der das bei Twitter öffentlich
gemacht hat das ist eine ganze Reihe von
Unionsabgeordneten gibt die geweitete
Teile dieses Gesetzes zum sogenannten
Chancen Aufenthalt Leben nicht ablehnen
sondern sich enthalten weil sie Teile
dieses Gesetzes nur für falsch im aber
viel Dinge die im Prinzip richtig
befinden darunter sind Abgeordnete wie
Hermann Gröhe Antje Tillmann Roderich
Kiese Wetter Armin Laschet über und Marc
was Marco wanderwitz Anja Karliczek oder
Annette Wiedmann Mauz wir sind zurück in
der Debatte und es spricht Addis
Ahmetovic für die SPD-Fraktion
wie zu unserer Gesellschaft und zu
unserem Land gehören wenn wir
beschließen heute im Deutschen Bundestag
das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht damit
beginnen wir eine Neuanfang in der
Migration und Integrationspolitik wir
schaffen eine neue Grundlage für eine
notwendige Anerkennungskultur ich freue
mich als hannoverscher
Bundestagsabgeordneter und Bürger dieses
Landes an diesen redepot zu stehen und
zu diesem Gesetz zu sprechen ob ich mir
das jemand hätte träumen können ich weiß
es nicht aber jetzt ist es Realität
geworden aber wenn man sich die Jahre
davor anguckt war es nicht vorhersehbar
meine Geschichte beginnt 93 in Hannover
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland meine
Eltern sind zusammen mit meinem älteren
Bruder aus Bosnien nach Deutschland
gekommen ich bin in Hannover geboren ein
waschechtes Hannover Kind Schule Studium
und Arbeit alles in Hannover gemacht
mein Zuhause das klingt so weit erstmal
nach einer normalen Kindheit das war sie
jedoch nicht ich habe mir bewusst einen
Auszug geben lassen von dem zust einem
Ordnungsamt zu meiner
aufenthaltsgeschichte um gemeinsam mit
Ihnen den behördlichen Spießrutenlauf
nachzuvollziehen alles ahmetic von 93
bis 2001 18 Duldungen zwischen ein Monat
und drei Monaten dazwischen eine
Androhung auf Abschiebung und eine
ausreiseaufforderung wie Sie sehen
können hat es nicht geklappt jetzt bin
ich direkt die Welt der
Bundestagsabgeordneter
dann fast vier Jahre
einbürgerungsprozess mit Abgabe der
bosnischen Schätze gewinnenischen
Staatsbürgerschaft was mir nicht leicht
fiel aber auch daran arbeiten Jana
doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft und das ist
auch ein richtiges Zeitpunkt
seit 2015 glücklicher deutscher
Staatsbürger und eine Meldung nach
rechts
Schwarz-Rot-Gold die Farben garnieren
nicht Ihnen das gehört den
demokratischen Demokraten das lassen wir
uns nicht nehmen ist nämlich das
grundgesetzbuch
und all das diese behördlichen Gänge
allein diese unsägliche Praxis der
kettenduldigungen damit ist ab heute
Schluss und das ist auch gut so meine
Damen und Herren das ist auch gut so es
ist ein Zeichen im Sinne von fernes
Partizipation Anerkennung Respekt aber
es ist auch ein Zeichen für viele
BundesbürgerInnen und Bundesbürger ein
spätes Eintreffen von Gerechtigkeit für
so viele harte Schicksalsjahre und die
Gerechtigkeit sieht heute mit dem
Beschluss des Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
für viele Menschen beginnt damit ein
neues Leben Deutschland hat dieses neue
Gesetz nicht nötig und die Menschen
haben es verdient in einem
Einwanderungsland zu leben mit
Anerkennung Respekt und Wertschätzung
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und
vielen Dank für dieses Engagement
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Detlef Seif
[Applaus]
so vielen Dank Herr amethovic für ihren
Redebeitrag sie sind ein gutes Beispiel
dafür dass auch in den 16 Jahren es
funktioniert hat dass Menschen die
qualifiziert sind im Ergebnis ohne auch
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht hier die
Möglichkeit erhalten vielen Dank für
Ihren Beitrag
so jetzt kommen wir mal zu einem Punkt
über den wir noch gar nicht gesprochen
haben jedenfalls nicht vertieft sie
öffnen die Integrationskurse und auch
die Sprachkurse für alle die zu uns
kommt
alle wissen die Kapazitäten dieser Kurse
sind eng begrenzt wir haben zu wenig
Lehrer das heißt die die wir integrieren
wollen haben jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten
Kurse zu halten sie versetzen die jetzt
mit den Menschen die aus sicheren
Herkunftsstaaten kommt die demnächst
vollziehbar ausreisepflichtig sind in
direkte Konkurrenz und das ist nicht
verantwortungsvoll meine Damen und
Herren
und das vorgesehene
chancenaufenthaltsrecht Kollegin launert
Kollege tromhams ja schon gesagt aber
ich vertief das an der Stelle noch mal
das ist ein Sonderrecht für die Menschen
die nicht mitgewirkt haben die getäuscht
haben warum ist das klar sie geben sie
geben die Gelegenheit anderthalb Jahre
die Voraussetzungen nachzubessern eine
Voraussetzung ist nach § 5
Aufenthaltsgesetz dass die Identität
geklärt ist meine Damen und Herren warum
soll denn bei jemandem der mitgewirkt
hat der alles offengelegt hat nun
plötzlich in anderthalb Jahren es
möglich sein dass seine Identität
geklärt wird das ist nicht möglich nur
ein Ausnahmefällen das heißt das trifft
dem Ergebnis nur die die getäuscht haben
die nicht mitgewirkt haben und da machen
wir nicht mit
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkung aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
[Applaus]
Frau Brunner
für die Zwischenfrage Herr Seif sie
waren doch am Montag auch in der
Anhörung und da haben unsere Expertin
doch gesagt wie die Situation bei
Menschen ist die ihre Papiere nicht
beibringen wollen können und das ist
Länder gibt und Botschaften gibt die
einfach Papiere nicht ausstellen das ist
die Realität in der viele Menschen leben
und möchten Sie das negieren möchten Sie
sagen diese Realität existiert nicht wie
sollen Menschen denen ist faktisch
unmöglich ist weil sie einfach alles
getan haben das wurde auch gesagt von
den sachverständlich alles getan das
maximale getan um die Papiere zu
besorgen und es ist ihn faktisch
unmöglich wie können Sie diesen Menschen
diese Realität wie können Sie das so
negieren und wie können sie das den
Menschen einfach so krass werden ich
verstehe es einfach nicht
Frau Brunner sie gehen auch hier der
Argumentation der Ampel auf den Leim
denn denn diesen Personenkreis den sie
geschildert haben den gibt es das
Problem wird durch das Gesetz aber nicht
gelöst werden das heißt wenn diese
Personen auch die Dokumente in den
anderthalb Jahren die ja vorher nicht
geliefert werden können ich liefern
können kommen sie trotzdem nicht über
den Paragraph 5 Aufenthaltsgesetz hinaus
das heißt da werden wir in der Zukunft
darüber nachdenken müssen die CDU fragt
CDU CSU-Fraktion wird auch demnächst
intern
asylkonkurrenzkonferenzen machen das
Thema ist nicht gelöst und danke für die
Frage dass sie es nochmal gesagt haben
es gibt das Problem aber dieses Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht begünstigt wirklich nur
die täusche und die die nicht mitgewirkt
haben
so meine Damen und Herren und Sonntag
immer gucken wie sind Behörden belastet
was bringt denn ein Gesetz überhaupt sie
reden hier von 136.000 Personen die
betroffen sind die Bundesregierung
selbst sagt in ihrem Entwurf 96.000
werden voraussichtlich ein Antrag
stellen und die schätzt dann großzügig
dass
33.000 Menschen letztlich die
Voraussetzung erfüllt haben die Behörden
müssen rund 100.000 Anträge prüfen wir
haben einen rechtskreiswechsel von
asylbewerberleistungen SGB II das heißt
wir haben zwei Behörden wir haben
demnächst 65.000 km zurück in die
Duldung kommt das heißt Behörden werden
hier doppelt belastet und das ist auch
in der Anhörung deutlich gesagt worden
und deshalb das Gesetz ich kann es nur
noch mal sagen ist nicht durchdacht ist
Mut hält nicht das was sie versprechen
das ist kein Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
für geduldete die nicht getäuscht haben
und die mitgewirkt haben und deshalb
bleibt uns nichts übrig das ist
Schule vielen Dank
das war Detlef Seif und Detlef Seifer
der vorletzte Redner in dieser
Aussprache ist folgt jetzt noch
Sebastian Hartmann der innenpolitische
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion und dann wird
es hier erstmal ein paar Abstimmungen
geben aber vorher noch Sebastian
Hartmann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger ich glaube
dass die heutige Debatte heute morgen
noch mal deutlich gezeigt hat wo
eigentlich das Problem ist auf der
Nationalkonservativen Seite in diesem
Land verweigert sich immer mehr Menschen
der Realität was Einwanderungsland
Deutschland angeht und damit machen wir
heute Schluss
und es ist
offenbar meine Damen und Herren der
cdu/csu-fraktion nicht gelungen die
meinungsbreite die offenbar in ihrer
Fraktion existiert angesichts der Rede
ist und der reden die wir heute
vernommen haben vernünftig abzubilden
denn wir haben ganz andere Stimmen auch
aus der cdu/csu verloren in der laden
Sie herzlich dazu ein wir konzentrieren
uns mal auf die Fakten und der erste
fakt ist wer hat uns in diese Lage
gebracht
cdu/csu Innenminister liebe
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger sie sind
verantwortlich für den Rechtsstand und
sie haben diese Realität in dem Land der
beigeführt und es ist unwürdig Menschen
in Kettenbildung zu lassen mit den
Kollegen der 18 kettendungen hatten
wollen sie das Fortführen das kann doch
nicht die Antwort sein meine Damen und
Herren
wir stellen uns der Realität und das
bedeutet dass es über eine viertel
Millionen Menschen geht von denen
137.000 Menschen endlich eine echte
Perspektive bekommen und in Wirklichkeit
geht es um etwas das viel weitergeht als
über diese 137.000 Menschen die schon
lange in Deutschland leben die sich
integrieren die dabei sind die sich für
unser Land entscheiden etwas wollen
davon brauchen wir doch viel mehr
Menschen und Millionen von Menschen
erwarten pragmatische progressive
Politik und das wäre endlich mit dieser
verkrampften Einwanderung und
Asylpolitik aufhören liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
wir wollen pragmatische Lösungen wir
wollen nicht wünscht dir was sondern wir
sind hier an der Realität angekommen und
wir hören mit diesem Zustand auch auf
und damit schaffen wir ein Bleiberecht
wir haben eine Lösung gefunden dass
innerhalb von 18 Monaten das beigebracht
werden kann und eine echte Chance
gegeben wird darum heißt es Chancen
Aufenthalt und hören Sie bitte auf immer
wieder neue Fake News zu verbreiten das
kann man nicht anders bezeichnen es ist
eine einmalige Regelung um die Zeit zu
nutzen zu einer dauerhaften Lösung im
Aufenthaltsrecht zu kommen um die Fragen
der Staatsbürgerschaft zu beantworten um
endlich ein modernes Land zu schaffen
Deutschland ist ein Einwanderungsland
und wir bilden das ab und die
fachkräfteeinwanderung kommt auch noch
dazu liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ihnen ist es nicht gelungen
zurückzuführen werfen Sie uns nicht
einen rückführungsbeauftragten vor wir
haben in unserem Koalitionsvertrag einen
Beauftragten für Migration benannt sie
verhetzen es mit diesen Worten so geht
es nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und im übrigen haben sie in dieser
ganzen Situation ein einziges dagegen
und ein weiter so gesetzt alles was
fehlt ist ein einziger Vorschlag aus der
Union und das ist keine konstruktive
Oppositionspolitik liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist viel zu wenig
wir haben eine klare Botschaft gesendet
diejenigen die gut integriert sind die
unsere Sprache sprechen die eben auch
den Lebensunterhalt nachweisen können
all das sind klare Anforderungen klare
Regeln und das ist nicht nur im
Interesse von 137.000 Menschen der von
betroffen sein können die wir herzlich
dazu einladen einen solchen Antrag zu
stellen es ist im Interesse von 82
Millionen Menschen in diesem Land es
geht um uns alle liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und die Menschen die sich jetzt für
unser Land entscheiden können die fehlen
doch in den Betrieben die fehlen doch
dann wenn Sie gefragt werden in der
Wirtschaft das sind Menschen die wir
hier herzlich einladen und das was jetzt
hier gemacht wird ist eine Lösung zu
bieten und das ist in den vergangenen
Jahren nicht gelungen und darum lade ich
alle Kolleginnen und Kollegen dazu ein
die auch die vergangenen Jahre im
Innenausschuss erlebt haben einer
Verweigerungshaltung der Union noch und
Löcher springen sie auch in der cdu/csu
werden Schatten sie haben die großartige
Chance heute für ein modernes Chancen
Aufenthalt zu sprechen das ist nicht
ausschließlich auf die Ampel beschränkt
und wenn die linke sich nur zu einer
Enthaltung durchdringen kann glauben Sie
uns wir haben mit diesem
Koalitionsvertrag eine so grundlegenden
Wechsel angestoßen sie müssen sich nur
darauf einlassen wir erkennen Realitäten
an dafür müssen wir endlich ohne Scheu
und Träumereien Realitäten anerkennen
und ein modernes Land schaffen und daran
arbeiten wir jeden Tag liebe Kolleginnen
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Einführung eines
chancenaufenthaltsrechts dazu liegen mir
mehrere persönliche Erklärungen nach §
31 unserer Geschäftsordnung vor
der Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat
empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
4.700 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksache
3.717 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die
Koalitionsfraktionen wer stimmt dagegen
das sind die Fraktionen der cdu/csu und
die afd-fraktion Enthaltung die Fraktion
DIE LINKE das der Gesetzentwurf ist
und einige Enthaltungen aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion
der Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung angenommen dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung die Fraktion der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP haben
namentliche Abstimmung verlangt
unmittelbar nach Eröffnung der
namentlichen Schlussabstimmung stimmen
wir noch über weitere Vorlagen ab bitte
daher die Abgeordneten noch im Saal zu
bleiben
die abstimmungserfolgt in der westlobby
wie immer sie haben gleich dann auch für
die Stimmabgabe 20 Minuten Zeit
die schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer
haben ihre Plätze bereits eingenommen
das ist der Fall damit eröffne ich die
Schlussabstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf
der Bundesregierung die abstimmungsurnen
sind bis
10 und 49 50 würde ich mal sagen
[Musik]
geöffnet ich werde das noch rechtzeitig
bekannt geben das bevorstehende Ende
nicht nicht unser aller Ende sondern
dass der Abstimmung
wir gehen weiter in der Abstimmung liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Abstimmung über
den von den Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zu
Beschleunigung der asylgerichtsverfahren
und Asylverfahren der Ausschuss für
Inneres und Heimat empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
4.703 den Gesetzentwurf auf Drucksache
4.327 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die den
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die koalitionsfraktion wer
stimmt dagegen
dass die Fraktion der cdu/csu
afd-fraktion und die Fraktion DIE LINKE
Enthaltungen
sehe ich keine der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit in zweiter Beratung angenommen
dritte Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
das sind die
Koalitionsfraktionen wer stimmt dagegen
die cdu/csu-fraktion und die
afd-fraktion die Fraktion DIE LINKE
Enthaltungen
eine Enthaltung
zweieinhalbungen der Gesetzentwurf ist
damit auch in dritter Beratung
angenommen
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion DIE LINKE zur
Änderung des Aufenthaltsgesetzes
deutschnachweise beim Ehegatten Nachtzug
der Ausschuss für Inneres und Heimat
empfiehlt unter Buchstabe b seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 4.700
den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion Die Linke
auf Drucksache 1.000
850 abzulehnen ich bitte diejenigen die
dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um
das Handzeichen das ist die Fraktion DIE
LINKE
wer stimmt dagegen
das sind die übrigen Fraktionen im Hause
Enthaltungen
keine der Gesetzentwurf ist in zweiter
Beratung abgelehnt damit entfällt nach
unserer Geschäftsordnung die weitere
Beratung
wir kommen zur Beschlussempfehlung des
Ausschusses für Inneres und Heimat zu
dem Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke mit
dem Titel keine
abschiebeoffensive für ein wirksames
Bleiberecht der Ausschuss empfiehlt
unter Buchstabe d seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 4700
den Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke auf
Drucksache
3973 abzulehnen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Fraktion spd-bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP cdu/csu und afd-
sehe ich nicht die Beschlussempfehlung
ist damit angenommen
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 31
erste Beratung des von der Fraktion der
cdu/csu eingebrachten Gesetzentwurfs zur
weiteren Beschleunigung von Planungs-
und Genehmigungsverfahren an Brücken und
Bundesfernstraßen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
so meine Damen und Herren da sind wir
noch mal im Plenarsaal jetzt noch ein
bisschen stylorücken im übertragenen
Sinne denn diese Stühle kam er
eigentlich nicht verrücken höchstens
nach vorne und nach hinten schieben es
wird abgestimmt nach wie vor über das
sogenannte Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht das
Viet namentlich abgestimmt sie sehen die
Abgeordneten einige der Abgeordneten
noch in der West Lobby auf der
Plenarsaal Ebene des Deutschen
Bundestags ihre Stimmkarten einwerfen in
die abstimmungsurnen